foreign
well Jade I thought it would be fun to
play a little clip as we like to do when
it's you know it's a Friday we're
hanging out we're having a good time and
uh there's this guy out there named
Caleb Hammer have you heard of him love
that dude he's a he's a big YouTuber
he's got almost half a million uh
subscribers over there and he's become a
friend of ours yeah yeah he actually
followed the Ramsay principles he has
veered off we don't agree on everything
that's okay but when it comes to
budgeting and spending and not being
stupid with money we agree 100 love it
and so I wanted to play a video for you
and get your take on it and I think it
will spark an interesting discussion so
here we go with some Caleb Hammer
YouTube clips I just use the cards for
some points
games you're losing to 11.50 what
what everybody needs something if I'm
not getting the point eleven dollars a
month because you're not fully painted
off why add to the balance effort
because this is how they get you and it
works on most people and worked on me so
everyone said it with me
you're not a credit card person it's
okay that you're not do you know what
that means that I don't use them
correctly is that you you suck at them
they're getting money from you you're
not getting any benefit from them
oh my goodness he is wildly entertaining
wow he let her have it didn't he that's
his whole Channel they're called
Financial Audits and he'll just sit down
one on one and just yell at someone as
he goes through their Bank transactions
I don't want to do that it sounds like a
good time yeah we we hope to do a little
collab with him soon for uh for our
YouTubes and we'll have a good time with
that that is great I hope he doesn't
yell at me I'm nervous but that really
summed up an entire generation's
mentality when it comes to credit cards
I don't think anybody should be a credit
card person this idea that like well
yeah this is how no but I like the I'm
doing it for the points do you
understand America that getting one
percent cash back and paying 20 interest
means you're losing
losing my back you don't have that's
first grade math yeah twenty percent
negative bad one percent positive not
even close to good yeah and so here's
what people are saying when they say
well I'm gonna do the credit card game
I'm going to hope for the two percent
cash back which by the way just basic
math here Jade average household income
70 grand okay take-home pays 48. you
can't put everything on a credit card
you can't put your mortgage you can't
put your utilities facts so that brings
it down to about what twenty four
thousand in actual dollars you could put
on a credit card yeah
two percent
of twenty four thousand dollars
you're talking about 500 bucks a year if
you're lucky
biscuits so you can get access to the
AmEx Lounge once a year so you can get
500 airline miles which doesn't even
equate to 500 actual traveling miles so
you can get a one-way flight from
Nashville to Boise oh
it does not make it make sense Jade I
can't it I can't it's so ridiculous the
the amount that you would need to spend
for this to
I mean two percent everyone that opens a
credit card says well I'm gonna pay it
off every month it'll be fine I'll pay
it off like tomorrow I'll just take
advantage of the bonus the sign up offer
the rewards the miles and then I'll be
done and it doesn't work out that way
when I have those conversations I feel
Dumber afterwards because the the the
logic in the rhetoric is just so
mind-numbingly stupid and I'm like no no
no no no we get a lot of flack this is
probably our hottest most controversial
take here at Ramsey Solutions is that we
are very I cut up the credit cards stick
to debit and we get so much Flack even
from our fans who I know we call him
Dave ish Jade because they're not all in
they're ish and they go I like the I
like the debt snowball but when I'm not
getting rid of my credit card because I
love XYZ yeah the credit card companies
are doing their job they're doing their
jobs marketing so well that you all out
there defend them you're defending these
billion dollar companies putting their
names on stadiums while they keep
America broke how do I know that because
credit card debt debt has hit one
trillion dollars a world record
congratulations Trillium
America has to be number one at
everything and uh we did it Jade a
trillion dollars in debt oh and what
what is our Parting Gift George
uh for for winning this accomplishment
well billions of dollars in interest
paid America staying broke amidst
inflation uh uh under the guise of
winning with their credit card Awards so
here's the here's the article from
payments.com I think is how you
pronounce it yeah yeah uh and it says
last year was a different story when it
came to credit card debt as inflation
ate away at people's savings the Federal
Reserve increased interest rates against
this backdrop credit card debt surged by
a record 86 billion dollars in the
closing quarter of 2022 spending is
non-stop now we once thought of putting
things on our credit card as frivolous
spending like TVs and big purchases
now because of inflation people are
putting actual Necessities like food and
housing on their credit card some people
some people are still going ham on
Lululemon has done better than ever
so we know people are yes there's some
folks struggling in that way but there's
a still a huge percentage of people who
have just said I liked my lifestyle
before and even though inflation it's
it's more expensive out there I don't
want to change my lifestyle so I'll just
use credit cards to float it well and
they go well I have no other option Jade
I was forced to because of inflation
without looking in the mirror and going
maybe you shouldn't have got that car
with a 600 a month payment okay maybe we
shouldn't have ignored student loans for
the last three years while we could have
actually made progress on them it's the
Comfort maybe we shouldn't have bought a
house because everyone said renting was
a sin and now we have a giant mortgage
payment and we can't afford to fix the
HVAC
and on top of all that credit card
companies are making record profits
because of these interest rates the
average credit card interest rate is now
almost 21 percent compared to 16 last
spring wow and that I think that for
like if you've had
or even higher oh yeah intro rates are
almost 22 introductory APR and you know
what APR stands for added pain and
regret oh there it is that's all it is
that's scientific for your two percent
cash back
and this doesn't just affect people with
lower incomes who are struggling this is
the high income folks as well if you've
been listening to this show for the last
20 minutes you know that this you're
they're not immune to it just because
they make six figures especially as we
see more layoffs inflation people are
are struggling out there and it's one
more reason to avoid credit cards not to
join one to go this is the solution to
my problems I can still go on vacation
this year if I get enough points that's
an insane way to live and it's exactly
what the credit card companies want they
want you to be in the Maze chasing the
cheese yeah well they don't they they
want you to it's one of those things
where our brains would rather we would
rather do what we want to do right now
than think about how it could affect our
future yes that's just the way we're
wired we are very short-term in the
moment we don't want to think about that
and credit cards are like yes we will
take advantage of that and we will make
it to where you seemingly feel no pain
until the hammer drops hey hey you feel
that Caleb man you feel the pain you
know what I'm saying so I'm glad that
we're out there Caleb hammers out there
telling people the truth even when it
hurts even we have to yell at you
because we want you to win financially
and too many people out there like Jay
don't tell me how to live my I'm trying
to live my truth out here your truth is
that you're broke and we want to see you
retire with dignity and break
generational curses yes